we're here to present the award from
makeup and hairstyling it's impossible
to overstate the role that hair and
makeup play in the craft of filmmaking
case in point I'm 87 years old and I'm
Charlize Theron
[Applause]
as actors our transformation starts in
the makeup and hair trailer listen I all
joking aside I do want to say I saw a
first hand how talented hair and makeup
people are in the irishman they would
transform us every day I would just sit
there and be amazed and then Pesci would
come in and say get the [ __ ] out of my
chair yeah I think they're gonna believe
that not everything is Netflix ray I got
carried away everyone woke up there
here are the wonderfully talented
artists nominated this year for
achievement and makeup and hairstyling
bombshell Kazuhiro and Morgan and Vivian
Baker Joker Nikki Laderman
and Kay Giorgio Judy
Jeremy would help
Maleficent mistress of evil Paul Gooch
our young Titan and David White 1917
Naomi dawn Tristan ruse loss and Rebecca
coil and the Oscar goes to bombshell
[Applause]
this is the second Oscar and fourth
nomination hero
the first Oscar and nomination for Ann
Morgan and Vivian Baker thank you very
much it's a great honor and we would
like to thank members of Academy in
director J Lo's and Charles and off Bob
graph Karen Grijalva score no headaches
Michela and Dave Johnson and the entire
team at brown studio and Lionsgate and
the cast and crew and friends and family
for the amazing support and my mentors
Rick Baker and Dick Smith and we would
like to give our heartfelt thanks to
Sharon Sarah you're amazing you are
amazing actor and producer your
compassion and love and care made this
film possible and because of your
bravery and passion we are able to set
the new bar in the makeup industry and
create a new way to tell stories thank
you very much and it will we wouldn't be
getting this award without you
[Applause]